سمكة مسالمة دخلت في حرب القروش
في البحر الأسود،
قطر دولة بحجم قرية، هذه الدولة الصغيرة
قد تكون سبب في إشعال الحروب،
لكنها قد تكون هيروشيما أخرى أيضا،
فالدب الروسي لن يرحمها،
وقد تكون في مرمى صواريخه
اذا اندلعت الحرب العالمية الثالثة
كونها مصدر طاقة لأعداء بوتين،،
سياسات قطر وعلاقاتها ليست كتنظيم كرة القدم،
الدوحة التي فازت بشرف تنظيم كأس العالم،
لن يكون لها ذات الشرف حال دخلت
حرب العالم الثالثة، القطريون
بين مطرقة أمريكا والغرب وسندان روسيا
وبكين وحلفائهم، في قضية أوكرانيا
قطر تكاد تخرج عن حيادها،
فما هو السبب الذي جعلها تغرد خارج السرب العربي؟
قطر أمسكت العصا من منتصفها بداية الأزمة الحالية
، فحاولت الدخول كوسيط بين الروس والأوكران،،
قطر ساءت علاقاتها مع جيرانها الخليجيين
قبل أن تتحسن مؤخرا، قطر وتركيا
علاقات حافلة بالمشاريع مع بعض من المنغصات،
قطر السياسية في العصر الحديث!!!
(العلاقة مع روسيا)
في بداية الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية
اتخذت قطر موقفا محايدا،
مع ضغط أمريكي لتعوض قطر دول أوروبا
عن غاز روسيا في حال قرر الاتحاد الأوروبي
مقاطعة غاز موسكو،
خطوة كهذه ستجبر القطريين على عداء الدب الروسي،
الذي يعتبر كل دولة تشارك بطريقة أو بأخرى
ضد موسكو في هذه الحرب هي دولة عدوة،
والدوحة تعرف مالذي يعنيه عداء الدب الروسي،
فهل تدخل قطر مغامرة كهذه؟
مع وصول طلائع القوات الروسية إلى الحدود الأوكرانية
اتصل البيت الأبيض بالرياض ضاغطا وطالبا
بزيادة إنتاج النفط للحيلولة دون ارتفاع أسعار النفط
الخام نتيجة الغزو الروسي.
غير أن السعودية أبلغت حليفها الأمريكي
بعجزها عن تلبية الطلب لأنها ملتزمة باتفاق
أوبك +(بلس) لعام 2020 مع روسيا
القاضي بخفض الإنتاج والحد من انهيار الأسعار.
أما الإمارات فذهبت الى أبعد من ذلك
وامتنعت في مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة
عن التصويت على مشروع قرار رعته واشنطن
يدين تصرف روسيا ويطالب بانسحابها.
يضغط الجانب الأمريكي على الدوحة لتكون
المنقذ لأوروبا بالغاز الطبيعي لكن قطر
تعتبر موردا رئيسيا للغاز لدول شرق آسيا كالصين
والهند وباكستان،،
الصين والهند تستوردان ٢.٢ مليون طن من الغاز القطري،،
الصين أكبر حلفاء روسيا في العالم،
بكين لن تترك أي تحرك من قطر
لتقليل صادراتها من الغاز دون رد،
خصوصا وأن العلاقات بين الدولتين تتسم بالإيجاب
في الفترة الحالية،،
فالصين أصبحت أكبر شريك تجاري لقطر
لمدة عامين متتاليين. وبلغ حجم التجارة الثنائية
في عام ٢٠٢١، نحو ١٢ مليار دولار
فهل تترك قطر تجارة كهذه مع الصين
لتقف مع الطرف الغربي؟
الرئيس الأمريكي جو بايدن يزيد من الضغوطات
على قطر ويعلنها حليفا استراتيجيا من خارج حلف الناتو،
لكن قطر لم تقم بأي خطوة في هذا الاتجاه بعد،،
فقطر تدرك المخاطر الجسيمة لسيناريو
تواجه فيه قوتين نوويتين على الأقل،
روسيا والصين، بتهديد وجودي.قد يتم محو قطر
من الخارطة في ظرف دقائق بواسطة الدب الروسي
لمشاركتها في حلف أعداء روسيا،
وإن فعلت ذلك فسوف تغرد خارج السرب الخليجي،
وهي خطوة بعيدة نوعا ما حاليا،
عام ٢٠٢٠ صدّرت روسيا 177.3 مليار
متر مكعب إلى أوروبا.
بينما صدّرت قطر 143.7 مليار متر مكعب
من الغاز في العام ذاته،،  ويتوقع أن تصبح الصين
أكبر مستورد للغاز الطبيعي المسال في العالم
في عام ٢٠٢٢، بقرابة ٤مليار متر مكعب
من الغاز وتعتبر قطر أبرز موردي الغاز لبكين...
ومع صعوبة إبداء قطر لموقف واضح ضد
الحرب الأوكرانية تحاول الدوحة الوساطة
لحل الأزمة الأوكرانية،
لكن موقف أمريكا من قطر قد يحول نظرة موسكو
للدوحة كعدو على بنك الأهداف
فما الذي سيفعله القطريون أمام معضلة كهذه؟
(قطر والخليج)
في يوم 5 يونيو 2017 قررت كل من:
السعودية، البحرين، الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
مصر، وتبعتها اليمن، و بعض الدول العربية
قطع العلاقات الدبلوماسية مع دولة قطر.
لكن تلك القطيعة التي استمرت نحو عامين ونصف
بدأت تشهد تغيرات إيجابية قبيل انعقاد القمة الخليجية
الأربعين في الرياض ديسمبر 2019،
خصوصا مع تأكيد وزير الخارجية القطري
محمد آل ثاني وجود مباحثات سرية
بين السعودية وقطر. وفي 4 يناير 2021
أُعلن عن فتح الأجواء بين قطر والسعودية،
كما أُعلن أن أمير قطر سيترأس وفد بلاده
في القمة الخليجية بالسعودية. وصدر بيان
عقب القمة يُعلن انتهاء الأزمة وعودة العلاقات.
ليخرج بعدها ولي العهد السعودي، محمد بن سلمان،
ويصف الأزمة السابقة مع قطر بأنها "شجار
بين أفراد العائلة"، معتبرا أن أمير البلاد،
الشيخ تميم بن حمد آل ثاني، "قائد رائع".
بينما التقى أمير قطر، مع ولي عهد أبو ظبي
ونائب القائد الأعلى للقوات المسلحة الإماراتية،
محمد بن زايد  في بكين...
لقاء وإن أظهر الود فالإعلام القطري الإماراتي
يعيش حربا شعواء بين الطرفين فكل طرف يتصيد أخطاء الآخر
(قطر وتركيا)
في عام ٢٠١٨ أعلن أمير قطر،
أن بلاده ستستثمر في تركيا 15 مليار دولار
بشكل مباشر.
وتأتي قطر كأكبر سابع سوق إنشاءات
للشركات التركية، إذا افتتحت تركيا عام 2017
مكتباً تجارياً لها في الدوحة لتشجيع قطاع
الأعمال القطري للاستثمار في تركيا
وكانت قد تأسست لجنة استراتيجية عليا مشتركة
بين قطر وتركيا عام 2014، أسفر تأسيس هذه اللجنة
عن إبرام 68 اتفاقية متنوعة،..
حتى أنّ حجم التبادل التجاري الثنائي ارتفع
خلال السنوات العشر الأخيرة من 340 مليون
دولار أميركي، إلى 2.24 مليار دولار،
بما يقرب سبعة أضعاف
قطر وتركيا..
تحالفات سياسية وطيدة وأهداف اقتصادية،
غير أن تحسن العلاقات بين الإمارات وتركيا
تضع الكثير من علامات الاستفهام من جانب القطريين
وتنغص صفو علاقاتهم بأنقرة...
مع ذلك لا تتوقف الزيارات الرسمية المتبادلة
على أعلى المستويات بين البلدين وكذلك المشاورات
السياسية، حيث ترتبط الدوحة وأنقرة
بعلاقات استثنائية..
وتتشارك الدولتان توجهات سياسية
واحدة تعتمد الدبلوماسية وتفعيل جهود الوساطة
لحل النزاعات الدولية والإقليمية.
عام ١٩٧١ أعلنت قطر استقلالها
من الاحتلال البريطاني
قطر الدولة الصغيرة
التي لا تتعدى مساحتها 11.521 كم² فقط،
وكان مجموع السكان فيها عام 2013،
هو 1.8 مليون نسمة
قطر من الدول المرتفعة الدخل التي يدعمها
ثالث أكبر إحتياطيات العالم من الغاز وثالث عشر
أكبر إحتياطي مؤكد من النفط. وتُصنّف قطر
الدولة ذات أعلى دخل للفرد في العالم.
تعد قطر لاعباً رئيسياً مؤثراً في منطقة الشرق الأوسط.
بينما ستستضيف قطر كأس العالم لكرة القدم 2022
وستصبح أول دولة عربية تقوم بذلك .
قاعدة العديد الجوية هي قاعدة عسكرية قطرية
تقع جنوب غرب العاصمة القطرية الدوحة،
تضم القاعدة القوات الجوية الأميرية القطرية
و القوات الجوية الأمريكية و سلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني .استضافت القاعدة أكثر من 11,000
ألف ضابط وجندي أمريكي وأكثر من مائة طائرة تشغيلية.
استخدمت قاعدة العديد الجوية كقاعدة لوجستية
وقيادة للعمليات الأمريكية في أفغانستان والعراق.
مع قطرها الصغير وقاعدة سكانها الضيقة
تعتمد قطر بدرجة كبيرة على التعاون الخارجي
ودعم أمنها. إذ يبلغ قوام القوات المسلحة القطرية
11800 جندي وهي ثاني أصغر القوات المسلحة
في الشرق الأوسط.
تحاول قطر أن تلعب دورا أكبر من حجمها للوساطة
في الأزمة الأوكرانية بينما يجر الأمريكان الدوحة
إلى مستنقعهم، لكنهم إن سقطوا فلن يتمكنوا
من الخروج من ذلك المستنقع مع عداوة الدب الروسي،
فكيف لقطر أن تتجاوز محنة كهذه؟
...